[EN]  We want to avoid talking about neurodiversity related diagnosis because we want to avoid stigmatization and labeling this child, but we intentionally avoid talking about the neurodiversity diagnosis. Is this another kind of stigmatization and labeling a person?
[EN]  okay so if we know that a child is diagnosed with neurodiversity whether it's like autism or ADHD
[EN]  but we intentionally avoid talking about this mentioning about this because we don't to don't
[EN]  want to put a label on him is this practical is it bringing more benefits than it's a
[EN]  negative outcome and is by doing this are we also doing this becoming like another
[EN]  There's no form of discrimination, like labeling and stagnation.
[EN]  I'm not sure there's a good understanding of community psychology.
[EN]  We don't label anybody. We don't do.
[EN]  But what I presented today was more of an approach to
[EN]  whoever could be neurodivergent
[EN]  students, adults, anybody.
[EN]  We usually think about the systems that surround
[EN]  the visuals so there are some clients who find value in understanding what this
[EN]  thing going on in their brain is called so when you can put a name to it it can
[EN]  be very helpful. There are others who are opposite. They don't want to be seen as neurodiverse
[EN]  because it may feel shameful. So a more productive way of explaining neurodiversity to someone
[EN]  who doesn't want that label is to say, look, everyone's brain has strengths and everyone's
[EN]  brain has weaknesses. And the question is, have you learned to capitalize on your strengths
[EN]  and then you learn the skills that compensate for your weaknesses.
[EN]  So you can talk about neurodiversity without talking about neurodiversity in the language of strengths and weaknesses.
[ZH] 好 那就是其實有些人會不喜歡神經多樣性這個詞
[ZH] 會覺得很羞恥
[ZH] 那有些人得知自己是神經多樣性
[ZH] 以後會覺得有一種恍然大落的感覺
[ZH] 就喔這其實解釋了很多事情
[ZH] 所以其實每個人對於這個詞會有不一樣的反應
[ZH] 那如果今天這個人他並不喜歡神經多樣性這個詞的話
[ZH] 其實還是有別的方法可以去解釋
[ZH] 比如說我們可以說每個人的大腦都有不同的優勢跟劣勢
[ZH] 就是優缺點
[ZH] 那我們要學會的是怎麼樣去最大化你腦部的優點
[ZH] 那怎麼樣雖然你有缺點
[ZH] 可是你可以透過學習兩些技巧去補足這一塊
[ZH] 那你就可以用這樣的講法
[ZH] 然後不去提到神經中央心這個詞
[ZH] sometimes the labeling could help either the individual themselves or the
[EN]  I have students often who said he or she was diagnosed and so she needed special care during the exams
[EN]  or paper writing so i used to give her or him extra time or different ways of assessing her
[EN]  performance and things but student may abuse the system so uh i'm coming from both the systems and
[EN*]  individual side but we need to protect both the schools or whoever the policy side and individuals
[EN*]  So that's a difficult question that we need to pose for all of us, but we need to put ourselves on both sides.
[EN*]  and the second question is for Drew or Mr. Davis.
[EN*]  So for stress sensitivity, ADHD and ASD kids and who are easy to lose their temper, can you kindly share how you do practical coaching and then indulge them with internal drive?
[ZH] 可以實際分享你們如何實際教導
[ZH] 讓孩子能真正內化為持續的能力
[ZH] So for stress sensitivity
[ZH] ADHD and ASD kids
[ZH] 和人家很容易失去的感情,可以分享一下如何做教育的教育,然後用內容的經驗?
[ZH] 我喜歡用我的女兒的例子,當她是小孩子,三、四歲,我試著教她她的房間,我開始說,
[ZH] Skyler,我需要你去清洗你的房間,她就回到床,我真的不能做了!
[ZH] 那我想以我自己女人舉例子,我女人還小的時候,大概三、四歲的時候,我要她清理自己的房間,然後她就躺在床上說,我沒有辦法做到。
[EN]  the dirty clothes. Waited for her to do that. Skylar, I need you to pick up your toys and
[EN]  put them in the bin. Just waited for her to do that. Skylar, I need you to pick up your
[EN]  thousand stuffed animals and put them on the bed somehow and waited for her to do that.
[EN]  Within 10 minutes, the room was clean. So for her, she looked at everything as this mole,
[EN]  and felt like she could not do it until she felt that there was a way to do it by being broken up and so when our students, our children are overwhelmed, we have to look at what they have in common, like what is going on for them and break it up for them.
[ZH] 看他們的一切,然後把他們的一切。
[ZH] 那這邊有一個小技巧就是把大任務切成小任務
[ZH] 所以比如說跟女兒僵持不下
[ZH] 那後來Drew把他的任務切成很明確
[ZH] 就是你現在把髒衣服丟到髒衣蘭
[ZH] 玩具把他放在玩具桶
[ZH] 然後就是娃娃把他排在床邊
[ZH] 然後不一會兒房間就變成緊緊有條
[ZH] 那就是女兒一開始不想做
[EN*]  Okay, next question for Barry,
[EN*]  全面評估後開案入住的標準?
[EN*]  不好意思,這個我不太清楚。
[EN*]  Okay, so when you assess whether you are going to accept this case,
[EN*]  this adolescent, what's your standard?
[EN]  What's your standard? And with history of self hurting, do you accept clients like this?
[EN]  And do you evaluate if it fits with other peers already in your...
[EN]  Yeah, so that question is what's our screening process? What do we screen out?
[EN]  And there is a screen out criteria. We screen out students who are psychotic, actively psychotic.
[EN]  We screen out students who are actively violent. We screen out students who have no conscience. So this is the person that would hurt you and feel no remorse or no empathy and take zero accountability.
[EN]  That's called conduct disorder. We'd rule that out too. Students who have chronic obsessive-compulsive symptoms. Obsessive-compulsive disorder requires a specialty type of treatment. So we can work with OCD, but on the mild to moderate end of symptomology, not on the severe end.
[EN]  And then, finally, sexually acting out students, students who are sexual perpetrators, we would screen those out.
[EN]  The typical TLO student is neurodiverse, dealing with emotional disorders such as anxiety, depression, ADHD, oppositional defying disorder is pretty common.
[EN]  Many learning challenges, that's power for the cost for a TGL student, and students who have self-worth issues, self-esteem, that's pretty important as well.
[EN]  I would add that when it comes to cutting, we look at the purpose of it, right?
[EN]  If it is a suicidality and they're actively suicidal, we wouldn't accept them until they had suicidal thoughts only, but we do work with kids who do cut.
[EN]  Cutting is just a communication.
[EN]  Cutting is a client or a student signalling, I am distressed.
[EN]  Now, some students are going to cut because it's a social currency.
[EN]  They're doing it to try and fit in or they're playing an attention card.
[EN]  Other students do it because they're deeply distressed
[EN]  and they're trying to express or feel emotion.
[EN]  So cutting doesn't frighten us, we see it actually pretty frequently.
[EN*]  Now, if the cutting becomes deep, it could potentially be lethal, then that would be alarming to us.
[EN*]  But a lot of the cuts we see are typically someone acting out, saying, I need help.
[EN*]  They don't have to be able to pay for it.
[EN*]  For example, they don't have to pay for it.
[ZH] 或是可能有一些性犯罪的記錄
[ZH] 或者是有非常非常嚴重的強迫症
[ZH] 那這些就會是拒收的物件
[ZH] 但是TILOS的話
[ZH] ADHD、學長都是很常見的
[ZH] 那剛剛有提到就是智商的部分
[ZH] 就是如果今天這個智商
[ZH] 他意圖是要自殺的話
[ZH] 那可能就會拒收
[ZH] 可是如果今天他這個智商
[ZH] 他只是想要發出求救的訊號
[ZH] 或是他可能是在
[ZH] 就是話淺淺的
[ZH] 並沒有到致命性的話
[ZH] 其實這對兩位專業人士來說是很常見的
[ZH] 他們並不會大驚小怪或是感到害怕
[ZH] 所以是有智障的話是要看他的目的意圖是什麼
[ZH] 好那最後兩題是要給曾主任的
[ZH] 曾醫師我們想請問第一個是
[ZH] 神經多樣性是指個體和其他神經典型者
[ZH] 在神經發展上有所不同
[ZH] 那如果他們有其他共病的話
[ZH] 可以說他是正常人嘛正常人
[ZH] 就像世界上有不同的價值體系
[ZH] 所以我想請醫師適宜這一點
[ZH] 其實神經典型就是正常發展
[ZH] 神經多樣,有可能神經多樣的表現
[ZH] 適合神經典型的不一定
[ZH] 所以我覺得只是在我們的眼光去看
[ZH] 那個人的表現怎麼樣
[ZH] 就算他有神經多樣
[ZH] 跟剛剛前面題目一樣
[ZH] 你要不要把他Label不需要
[ZH] 他沒有產生什麼問題,而且他沒有產生公病
[ZH] 說沒有公病,說他沒有焦慮、憂鬱、想像習慧問題
[ZH] 那種問題之下,他不影響他生活
[ZH] 在家庭裡面也不需要給他類似,也不需要說他是否去診斷他
[ZH] 我覺得不需要去診斷,他是否活在這個世界上很正常的人
[ZH] 所以假如有產生,有發現有以後,早期只會看見十大警訊當中有的話
[ZH] 有做發育的一個評估,評估以後,知道以後早期開始介入
[ZH] 父母瞭解小孩怎麼樣,要怎麼面對他
[ZH] 然後陪伴他走過這段時間
[ZH] 他每天出問題的時候,發生任何問題的時候
[ZH] 不一定做不到要抓屁股出去,還是想下去
[ZH] 只要好好面對他,能夠渡過一個階段一個階段
[ZH] 還有從旁協助他去學習
[ZH] 與其他碰到問題的時候怎麼解決才重要
[ZH] 他能夠過了他18歲
[ZH] 減少數字散的機會
[ZH] 過了二、四歲
[ZH] 他腦還長差不多
[ZH] 他懂得用大腦錢去思考
[ZH] 他就過他的生活
[ZH] 世界上很多神經多樣性的人
[ZH] 家庭活著很明顯
[ZH] 他自己知道自己
[ZH] 他自己怎麼面對就可以了
[ZH] 我覺得應該雖然有這種分別
[ZH] 但是在生活當中我們會分泌以後
[ZH] 我覺得應該按照自然區處理就可以
[ZH] 不需要
[ZH] 但是它有共病後
[ZH] 你就以表現產生困難
[ZH] 你應該早期介入
[ZH] 不然它會進入黑道區的需求
[ZH] 跟其他問題出來
[ZH] 好 謝謝
[ZH] 那第二題也就是我們今天最後一題
[ZH] 請問要如何申請或瞭解
[ZH] 亞同醫院生活配法師的治療醫院
[ZH] 請詹醫師回答
[ZH] 生活配法師是剛剛從美國特有學來的
[ZH] 一個新的模特兒
[ZH] 也是因為臺灣,同樣的,大家很難找到有足夠的錢去找賽克斯人給心理治療
[ZH] 一個小時大概兩千到三千塊
[ZH] 還有你找精神科醫生,也要需要大概一兩次看到
[ZH] 所以我們跟社會局提到說,生活美好是一個很好的制度哦
[ZH] 你進來以後,進過區內完以後吧,可以寫出很多需要的青少年跟孩童的情況
[ZH] 所以這個部分也是剛起步
[ZH] 社會局剛剛給我們
[ZH] 今年底前有辦一個基礎課程
[ZH] 明年度我們還有一個初階跟高階
[ZH] 大家就密切注意我們的公告
[ZH] 然後什麼時候有初階開展
[ZH] 明和都是有縣
[ZH] 因為社會局有提供的部分
[ZH] 我們在今年度會有出階高階訓練課程
[ZH] 什麼情況下會舉著證照
[ZH] 然後看看有時候合作
[ZH] 他們給我們多少的資源
[ZH] 我把國外的模特兒帶進臺灣
[ZH] 到處很多講師是國內的專家來講的規定
[ZH] 只要能夠達成任務
[ZH] 我們能夠讓陪跑師
[ZH] 他能夠學懂整個治療課程
[ZH] 所以今天整個課程當中
[ZH] 我們做連結的
[ZH] 早上講治病段
[ZH] 下午講到一些行為
[ZH] 會怎麼面對
[ZH] 怎麼這個類似不做
[ZH] 還有怎麼去做小心理事
[ZH] 都是一個連結性的議題
[ZH] 但是不是隻有一些邪惡
[ZH] 還有很多很多的討論
[ZH] 結果你懂了以後
[ZH] 還有出過Practice
[ZH] 有關那個討論以後
[ZH] 才能夠取得相關的一些證明
[ZH] 好的
[ZH] 今年是我們第三屆